[Music]  a bacterium is built with a biological  imperative if you try and kill it it's  not going to go oh okay kill me the  bacterium will do every maneuver  possible to stay alive well to be able  to survive you better be careful of  things that threaten you so i look at  the scary things i didn't look at the  good things i'm okay with them i got no  problem with that consciousness is  creating your reality if you put a  picture of fear into your reality then  your biology behavior will manifest  things to be afraid of the function of  the mind is to create coherence between  your beliefs and your reality if i have  a negative belief the function of my  mind is to manifest behavior to  experience those negative realities  if i have positive beliefs then the  function of my mind is to manifest the  positive experience but we get  programmed with so many negative beliefs  and that takes our power because we're  not focusing on the beautiful things  we're focusing on the fear